Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar. I received this Mathcounts problem by email from Bill.
Find all positive integers n for which n squared plus 45 is a perfect square.
Can you figure it out? Give this problem a try and when you're ready to keep watching the video for the solution.
Suppose n squared plus 45 equals a perfect square: x squared.
We now subtract n squared from both sides of the equation to get 45 equals x squared minus n squared.
We now can perform a little trick.
We have the difference of two squares and we can factor that as the product of x plus n and x minus n.
So we're looking for two factors of 45.
The possibilities for this can be 45 times 1, 15 times 3, and 9 times 5.
We now need to set the equations equal to these factors.
Since x plus n is larger than x minus n, we will set x plus n equal to the larger factor.
This is because x and n are positive integers.
So from the first possibility we set x plus n to equal 45 and x minus n to equal 1.
In the next possibility way of x plus n equals 15 and x minus n equals 3
We then have x plus n equals 9 and x minus n equals 5.
We can solve each of these equations for x and n.
In the first set of equations, for example,
we can add up the two equations to get that 2x is equal to 46,
and then we divide by 2 to get x is equal to 23.
We can then go back and solve that n is equal to 22.
We'll use the same trick for the next two equations as well.
We end up with x is equal to 9 and n equals 6 and then x is equal to 7 and n equals 2.
So you know three possibilities n can equal 22, 6 & 2.
And those are the only ways in positive integers that n squared plus 45 will be equal to a perfect square.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video. Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math.
You can catch me on my blog Mind Your Decisions that you can follow on Facebook, Google+ and Patreon you can catch me on social
media @preshtalwalkar and if you like this video, please check out my books; there are links in the video description.